eu nunca fui o melhor aluno para estudar
não tenho orgulhasse disso mas eu sei
que se poderia fazer é dificultar um
pouco as coisas no futuro passar no
vestibular ter um ter um bonde plomo
conseguir um bom emprego e ser mais uma
pessoa bem sucedida é aquilo que acha
que a sociedade nos ensina desde pequeno
mas ao mesmo tempo é possível enxergar
pessoas que construíram grandes legados
em suas em suas vidas sem ter passado
por bancos universitários ou escolares
naturalmente isso facilitaria muitas
coisas mais tirar boas notas nem sempre
quer é foi a regra do sucesso pois no
fim é tudo uma questão comportamental
por exemplo você pode até ser contratado
pelo seu currículo mas poderá ser
demitido pelo seu próprio comportamento
caso não souber lidar com questões
interpessoais do seu dia a dia
talvez gostasse de uma novidade outra na
escola mas nunca fui o cara mais
disciplinado precisar eu sabia que seria
cobrado pelos meus pais então eu
precisava passar de ano
eu precisava eu sabia que eu precisava
completar aquela aquele processo de de
ensino para iniciar outro ainda mais
importante na minha vida
a graduação jardim de infância até a
universidade estamos falando de uns 23
anos ou mais dentro de um sistema de
ensino com grandes dificuldades
estruturais poucos avanços expressivos e
até desestimulante
todas essas limitações serão refletidas
no nosso cotidiano querendo não seja
numa é é interação dentro da nossa
própria família seja na busca por um
novo emprego até na na construção de um
novo negócio
tudo isso irá refletir na construção de
cidadãos e profissionais com lacunas
lacunas até certo ponto e reversíveis
mas que precisarão ser preenchidas com o
tempo
só que a gente sabe que nem todo mundo
se preocupa com o tempo à medida que ele
passa hoje em dia é possível pensar
diferente se você quiser ter acesso a
alguma experiência é muito melhor do que
possuir certas coisas pois no fim elas
não serão as suas
mas o senso de posse e de
competitividade individual é algo que é
vendemos desde pequeno algumas situações
para clarificar o que eu tô falando como
sempre que você tem que aprender isso
fica na prova horas a prova individual e
sem consulta ela não inventa moda faz
como ensinei são frases que supostamente
são situações que supostamente muitos de
vocês ouviram com seus 14 e 15 anos de
idade eu lembro inclusive de led de
ouvir isso dentro da universidade
todas essas situações irão formatar
pessoas e profissionais que terão
poderão gerar graves consequências no
futuro
eu sou daqueles que acredita que o papel
da escola vai além de formar de de focar
em objetivos tão específicos como é
passar no vestibular ou ou ou ou focar
em carreiras tão específico pra mim o
papel da escola é ela deveria ser focado
no desenvolvimento de atributos e
desafios que a gente enfrenta dia a dia
sejam eles profissionais ou não
porém atualmente dificilmente somos
formados é pra enfrentar agra as grandes
diz os grandes desafios do dia a dia e
no fim muitas instituições de ensino a
vendem a idéia de uma educação visando o
futuro mas realizado com processos do
passado a ao entrar numa empresa nós a
nossas obrigações nossos papéis eles
crescem diariamente e no fim lidamos com
situações diferentes e desafiadoras que
somos obrigados a enfrentar cada dia que
passa
provavelmente vocês já ouviram as
situações do tipo a precisamos de mais
criatividade ou sejamos criativos ou
perderemos mercado daqui pra frente
precisamos é ter é trabalhar em equipe
saber como trabalhar em equipe e não
podemos ser mais tão individualistas e
competitivos aqui dentro eu não preciso
que me prove que sabe apenas me traga
resultado essas essas situações que não
poderão gerar graves conseqüências do
futuro
de acordo com a professora é da
universidade de stanford na silagem
o livro é ingênuos nós criamos molduras
para o que lemos vemos ouvimos e
experimentamos o dia inteiro e essas
molduras tão em forma quanto limitam o
raciocínio infantil a forma como
pensamos que essas gorduras tanto limita
é tanto limitam a o raciocínio infantil
que querendo ou não esses essas mudanças
serão refletidas na fase adulta ao mesmo
que a gente consiga enxergar esses
avanços ao mesmo que a a a vida passa
para a educação no país tem as suas
dificuldades e suas limitações das suas
molduras
sabemos que não podemos generalizar e
sabemos que há certos avanços
acontecendo com o tempo mas o fato é que
hoje todos nós estamos submetidos a uma
metodologia o predominantemente focada
em transmissão de conteúdos fragmentado
focada no consumo de curto médio prazo e
quase nunca focado no aluno e nas suas
reais necessidades
hoje é possível pensar diferente se você
quiser um retorno um pouquinho nervoso
só um pouquinho
a nossa vida não é algo moldado a uma
estrutura fixa que precisa de regras ou
de manuais
na verdade a nossa vida é uma sucessão
de acontecimentos e experiências que são
plena já planejadas ou não que irá nos
exige uma série de capacidades como a
análise crítica capacidade de
aprendizado inteligência emocional
flexibilidade resiliência muitas vezes a
capacidade é exigidas ao extremo ao
extremo
e são justamente essas capacidades que a
gente vê poucas vezes serem
desenvolvidas dentro da sala de aula
pelo menos que o conheceram e se
buscarmos um pouco da origem da palavra
escola veremos que o seu conceito o seu
significado é bem diferente daquilo que
a gente vê atualmente a escola vem do
grego escolher o que significa lazer ou
aquilo que se fazia na hora do descanso
escolas pois era quando gregos falavam
sobre filosofia e proporcionar momentos
é de de relaxamento e descanso e demais
assuntos discutidos na época lazer pois
é um momento de fato é era de fato um
momento de integração e relaxamento
atrelado ao conhecimento e é justamente
o lazer que que poucos que que aos
poucos estamos perdendo é hoje
hoje em dia com a educação precisamos de
uma escola precisamos de uma educação
que seja voltado ao lazer da experiência
algo muito mais dinâmico do que temos
hoje algo mais voltado ao ao prazer da
exploração algo que seja muito mais
dinâmico é flexível é que seja voltado a
a a experimentação que permita o erro e
o acerto seja muito mais do que a
simples acúmulo e coerção
olhando essas imagens e pra tentar
contextualizar um pouco sobre a real
situação do brasil é basta olhar um
pouco sobre essas duas imagens por
exemplo eu trouxe isso só para é
exemplificada um pouco sobre o atual as
atuais
limitações que estamos enfrentando no
nosso país
lembra um pouco dessas notícias ah eu
fico imaginando como eu poderia ser um
pouco mais pró ativo nessa história toda
como eu poderia tentar ajudar diante do
meu próprio potencial amenizar a
situação que tendam a se agrava ano após
a fico triste em saber que algo tão
importante na consolidação de um país no
crescimento de um país demore tanto para
vingar neste país
no fim eu acredito que a educação por
mais que seja um direito de cada
brasileiro a cada dia que passa torna se
um privilégio e olhando tudo isso aí a
gente precisa pensar um pouquinho
não adianta apenas culpar um lado o
salvará a cabeça de outro nessa história
todas todo mundo tem um pouco de culpa é
em função desse problema inclusive nosso
não adianta apenas condenar o político
por não é conseguir implantar os seus as
suas ideias os seus planos as suas leis
tampouco posso condenar o professor que
acima de tudo trabalho em condições tão
precárias limitadas que no fim não tem
nem sequer motivação profissional
pessoal ou sequer financeira
todas essas reflexões todas essas
situações essas limitações serão
refletidas no nosso dia a dia
aí eu pergunto pra vocês será que apenas
esses dois agentes sociais tão
importantes na nossa sociedade um
político professor são os reais os
únicos verdadeiros eheheheh responsáveis
pela construção de uma pátria mais
educadora
ou será que um é essa responsabilidade
não está dentro de cada um de nós também
de certa forma eu acredito que sim
e pensando nisso mais do que indignações
e redes sociais
eu acredito que é nosso dever puxar um
pouco dessa responsabilidade e expor e
trabalhar aquilo que a gente tem que tem
mais de especial dentro de nós o nosso
próprio potencial nosso próprio
conhecimento ea partir daí gerar um
pouco mais de de iniciativa positiva em
prol de um país com mais educação
mas como como podemos gerar esse
empoderamento das pessoas como eu vou
dizer pra vocês que vocês têm poder
suficiente e segurança pra ensinar o que
vocês sabem para alguém como eu posso
gerais esse poder e empoderamento para
as pessoas como eu vou poder há como
criar formas de articular novas
possibilidades e permitir que todo mundo
faça parte desse crescimento como eu
permito a como eu faço pra criar uma
educação mais democrática para todos os
envolvidos 1
essas e outras perguntas através dessas
é dessas e outras perguntas eu cheguei
numa resposta
bom estou dizendo aqui que todo mundo
faz parte de um país mais educador
todo mundo aqui tenho de ver de de
compartilhar um pouco que sabe e esse
dever de todo mundo então é preciso
construir uma fórmula em que isso seja
possível esquecer ou seja é sustentável
para todo mundo e todo mundo possa
contribuir para a educação do brasil de
alguma forma mas antes de tudo o que eu
tô querendo com isso o que existem
várias limitações do nosso sistema já
não é de hoje vive com grandes e graves
problemas
primeiro queria que a educação pudesse
estreitar as relações e fizesse é a a
troca de conhecimento algo muito mais é
humano e sensível entre as pessoas
eu queria que a educação pudesse
articular novas idéias e conexões entre
os envolvidos
eu queria que o lazer pudesse voltar ao
processo de aprendizado envolver ainda
mais pessoas
queria algo mais é intuitivo uma escola
mais intuitiva algo mais livre e
democrático tanto para quem ensina
quanto para quem aprende
eu queria algo que que pudesse
proporcionar uma experiência muito mais
simples e direta para as pessoas mas que
ainda gerasse benefício e que assim
chega-se valor nisso tudo é é como se
fosse uma uma experiência de sala de
aula muito mais democrática e acessível
para todas as pessoas e quando a gente
fala de experiência isso é um baita de
um fator essencial na construção do
processo de aprendizado treinou à
experiência conta muito nesse processo
de acordo com ele o glacier nós
aprendemos 10% do que vemos 1 95% do que
ensinamos para os outros 95%
se eu pegar todos esses elementos e
começará a juntar potencial de
eficiência que o brasil tá com essas com
essas limitações mas nós aprendemos 95
do que ensinamos nós temos a obrigação
de construir um país mas é mais educador
essa pátria educadora também nossa
responsável
logo é preciso conectar esses pontos e
nesse sentido eu construir três simples
valores que sustentaram a ideia que
sustentar esse projeto desde o início
primeiro eu precisava de um projeto algo
mais independente eu precisava que a
educação fosse mais independente daquilo
que existe hoje
ou seja você vai ensinar aquilo que você
sabe
baseado na forma que você quiser e ponto
alternativo porque você vai ensinar
aquilo que sabe será valorizado por isso
nós entendemos que conhecimento ele só é
validado se for compartilhado e nós
estamos aqui pra botar energia e você é
claro focado em pessoas algo presencial
olho no olho que estreitar as relações e
fosse ainda mais humano lembra que
existe uma frase que eu nunca vou
esquecer e que me ajudou a sustentar
essa idéia de que precisamos sim gerar
novos formatos de de conhecimento das
pessoas algo muito mais simples do que
temos hoje algo muito mais direto
você não quer mudar as coisas a lutando
contra uma realidade existente para
mudar algo construir um novo modelo que
fará o que existe se tornar obsoleto
nesse sentido a não basta apenas querer
é apontar os erros no sistema de certa
forma e querer que as coisas mudem
principalmente as que as coisas mudam de
um dia para o outro
eu sei que isso exige uma transição e
faz parte da caminhada humana
logo comecei a entender que as pessoas
precisam de um potencial esse potencial
pode ser atrelado a essa é a essa
transição e criar com e criar
alternativas
elas poderão ser complementares aquilo
que existe até de fato se tornarem
opções definitivas com o tempo a aos
poucos
essas opções essas alternativas
começaram a criar experiências e grandes
coisas foram vistas na vida real
por que não falar de artes plásticas com
esses kits de blumenau ou porque é um
cara falar sobre empreendedorismo mas
nunca te falar nunca ter tido uma
empresa antes na vida
um arquiteto que falou sobre pessoas
futuro sociedade brasil servindo caldo
de feijão e cachaça artesanal para as
pessoas
olha olha o processo independente de
ensinar da forma que ele quiser e ainda
se valorizado por isso ou dois amigos
colunista de um blog online que
ensinaram sobre storytelling para as
pessoas
outros dois amigos que ensinaram sobre
branding comunicação no terraço de um
prédio residencial aqui da cidade como
construir 11 projeto um edital para
captar recursos financeiros conceitos
sobre meditação conceitos sobre a cabala
conceito sobre contabilidade seja o que
for
isso tudo só aconteceu porque existia
uma simples forma no meio disso tudo
alguém queria compartilhar o pouco que
sabe que alguém queria aprender
no fim é expulso um uniu esses dois
lados
tudo isso aconteceu diante dessas
ingênua variável
aqui todo mundo tem um potencial interno
e que precisa ser explorado e uma vez
que isso é explorado
a gente sabe que muitas consequências
consequências inclusive positivas
poderão ser adquiridas com essa com esse
tipo de coisa
nós temos que gerar esse impacto
positivo cada vez mais intenso nas
pessoas nós temos que permitir que cada
vez mais pessoas mudar a vida das outras
pessoas através da educação
nós temos que permitir que mais pessoas
tenham essa a possibilidade de ter voz
de subir num palco e falar aquilo que
sabe ainda ser valorizada por isso nós
precisamos é entender que é preciso
saber argumentar mais nós precisamos
aprender a reaprender mais mas
precisamos saber que mesmo escrevendo
certo com linhas tortas isso também é
válido e merece e tem o seu valor
senhoras e senhores eu posso nunca ter
sido o cara mais inteligente da sala
disciplinado para estudar mas eu sei que
é mas eu sei que hoje em dia eu ainda
posso aprender muito com o cara que
ainda tira nota mais baixa na prova
porque no final de contas no final de
tudo eu repito enfatiza
todo mundo tem algo para compartilhar
inclusive cada um de vocês muito
obrigado